thank you
I'm gonna walk through these doors and
just kind of face that window on your
right right there for a minute
so
what's your name Chad Chad what's your
last name
Gorman dorm
have you ever been here before
really one time for
a fight with them
all right
yeah
just give me the word when you get it
and I'll
thank you
don't be doing nothing don't leave me
alone yeah
foreign
[Music]
thank you
Sean's
changed
just taking the belt off
[Applause]
you see the bombers
let's go
all right we're gonna step straight up
to the counter in front of that blue bag
there to the left
is he getting evidence backs or
push
ing your hands
I'm gonna take this cuff off put your
hand up here Palm down okay
foreign
go down to the end of the counter down
here we're gonna hang a left
you're fine you put your hands down to
your side
give me a gown yeah what size shoe you
wear
I'm going down here 10. size 10 shoe
go ahead and take your shirt off and
hand it to me
once we get done with the process and
they're finished with you yes we'll let
you make a phone call
[Applause]
hold on a second
there's jeans in there
I'm gonna take the boxes off
[Applause]
hold your hands up in the air
you see your mouth lift your tongue take
one finger go around your gum line top
and bottom please
all right let me see behind your ears
all right hello all right unless your
penis
with the testicles all right turn around
see the bottom of your left foot
wiggle your toes all right your left
foot now
all right face this wall squat down like
a baseball catcher and cough hard three
times
in our 448
people probably tomorrow they'll
probably talk to you at some point
tomorrow be my guess
um and then we'll go from there okay
okay stuff out here
I'm gonna step up on that sled
you're gonna face that Wall Street in
it
apart
the whole time don't move don't talk
take about 15 seconds
oh
foreign
[Applause]
step off towards me
there we go that way
all right
here
oh I'm staying right here
just place your hands up around the
counter